science breakthroughs daily from science  Mission Nero fibril formation is  hallmark of various neurodegenerative  diseases generally accepted bonded shows  first Miss folding and then aggregation  leading to the formation of neuro  fibrils the new model published in the  journal Nature communication suggested  first aggregation of proteins and then  misfolding leading to the fibril  formation next Mass related g-protein  coupled receptors that is mr. GPRS  mediate histamine independent each  researchers showed that cysteine  protease cathepsin s activates mr. GPR  and evokes receptor-dependent scratching  in mice and this activation did not  involve generation of tethered ligand as  in the case of other protease-activated  receptors thereby providing a newer  mechanism for activation of Proteus  receptors for more news visitors at www  science mission calm or science mission  facebook page thanks for watching